you know looking ahead at the playoffs
like y'all had the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
that would be a tough that'll be I think
all four the Giants the commanders the
Cowboys and the Eagles all from the NFC
West all made the playoffs like that's
ridiculous Cowboys versus the Buccaneers
uh commanders and the 49ers Vikings and
Giants like in this playoff football so
I don't know what's about to happen next
like
you know I could see that I don't even
want to I don't even want to speculate
but I will I see the Giants beating the
Vikings I see the 49ers beating the
commanders my bad I ain't trying to
start no beef with the commanders none
of that I see the Cowboys winning that
one then the Cowboys gonna play
uh the 49ers next and the Eagles play
the Giants
then I see the Eagles beating the Giants
again and then I see the Cowboys beating
the com the 49ers then I got the Cowboys
versus the Eagles and I got the Cowboys
beating the Eagles in the NFC
Championship Game and going to the Super
Bowl to play the
Buffalo Bills in the Super Bowl and that
one we just gonna have to see man we
just got to see that one
it's gonna pay me to go against Josh
it's gonna hurt me right I'm so glad I'm
on his team like because when I gotta
sack every time I play Josh you know I
got a sack on him every time I play it
every time I play you know Josh I got a
sack you know and I beat you know
Dawkins you know he you know I beat dog
I beat I beat Dion Dawkins like
give me uh what's the game playing SDI
let me know you know I tell you what
like and this is I'm not even guessing
I'm telling you the truth like
Diana's such he's so well around it you
know we talked about like smaller
tackles not he's not necessarily small
because he but he
he they say 340 pounds but he probably a
little bit heavier than that bro we call
him a slow man and he can move and he
athletic and all of that stuff so he can
he jump out there in your speed but then
he sit down on the speed of power so
it's like those little you know
intrinsic like movements like coming
from speed to power but to spin inside
you know those might be you know he
honestly don't have no vulnerabilities
but just man oh man like sport all all
you gonna win something he gonna win
something you're gonna win something man
yeah man he coaches like you cold and
just over time like y'all going Y'all
Gonna spark luckily we got Josh Allen
and you know he gonna you know I make
magic he know how to scramble and you
know get around
I got I got if he gonna if I'm gonna do
the AFC I got Chiefs over Patriots
I got dolphins
Chiefs Chiefs Patriots
I like Bengals over Titans again
Bengals over to Titans
um
Joe Bird yeah I like bear bird like Joe
bear Joe bird chase he's
T boy mix oh
and then who oh yeah Bill's dolphins
that rematch oh man man I ain't even
playing but we're about to start
you know that's like little brother he
ain't little brother call it Big Brother
come fight man I'm gonna call my brother
on y'all I ain't even playing this week
I don't think we're gonna beat him
bro I there's just no answer for uh
Tyrese a model right now bro
yeah it feels
I ain't gonna lie when we played them
when we played them early in the season
you know we had some success versus
though we lost but we had some success
and I think to be the NFL team twice is
super tough bro it is still but this is
the playoffs we would already won one
they won one this would be our third
game two
if two is on point which I've seen
honestly I think the bill I could
honestly dolphins being the AFC
champions this year
with their weapons they got and the
defense they got hold on I just went to
the NFC thing I went all the way bro I
told you I'm a realist I can't make
everybody happy you my dog
but I look at this Tyree and this waddle
man I could have said the eagle I know
and I will understand
but if it's not the Dolphins I like the
bills news bruh I told you a lot of
bills I love y'all too well luckily I
mean it's Gabriel like if it's not the
Dolphins I got the bills it's gonna be
the winner between the bills and the
Dolphins and the answer that's gonna be
the champion